Ça tourne
Musique s'il te plaît François !
Tu es si mignonne
Tu as de jolies oreilles
Ton sourire est comme une pomme
Qu’on croquerait au soleil
Tes longs cheveux blonds
Ont un parfum de vanille
Et sur ton menton
Une petite fossette brille
Tu as le petit nez
D’une petite fée
Et la peau douce et fine
Comme de la popeline
C’est pour toutes ces raisons que
Je me branle en pensant à toi
Puis je m’essuie sur mon chat
Ton spectacle est une féérie
Chaque soir j’essaie d’y venir
Je ne te respire qu’à la sortie
Et je n’aspire qu’à la sortir
Je te trouve plus belle
Que les deux Chevaliers du Fiel
Plus vivante que Desproges
Et t’as plus de bras que Jamel
Je ne suis jamais choqué
Quand tu dis des choses un peu trash
J’aime savoir que les énormités
Dans ta bouche ça passe
C’est pour toutes ces raisons que
Je me branle en pensant à toi
Puis je jouis sur mon chat
Pour Noel j’aimerais tant
T’envoyer un gros cadeau
Un joli cardigan
Pour que tu aies bien chaud
Mais je connais pas ta taille
Alors je l’ai fait essayer
A une collègue au travail
Qui m’a gentiment conseillé
Elle est très élégante
Elle s’appelle Claire, elle a ton nez
Et même que quand elle chante
C’est fou ce qu’elle peut te ressembler
C’est pour toutes ces raisons que
Je viole Claire en pensant à toi
Puis des fois je biffle mon chat (bien fait)
(choeurs)
Chaque soir j'essaie d'y venir (choeur)
(choeur)
Et je n'aspire qu'à la sortir (choeur)
Chante !
Tu... es si jolie...
Je me branle en pensant à toi...
Et je m'essuie sur... mon chat...
Tu dis que c’est pas très bien
Que je ferais mieux d’arrêter
Qu’à Noël sous ton sapin
Tu ne veux pas voir mon gros paquet
Et que depuis l’automne
Mon chat est tout collé
Comme un gros chewing-gum
Au papier peint de la cheminée
Mais c’est toi qui n’as pas compris
Qu’en fait c’est bien plus que ça
Je te suivrai jusqu’au bout de la nuit
Car je t’aime tu vois
C’est pour toutes ces raisons que
Je me branle en pensant à toi
Je me branle en pensant à toi puis
Je m’essuie sur mon chat
C’est pour toutes ces raisons que
Je me branle en pensant à toi
A me dire ce que je dois faire, tu n’as pas
Je suis quand-même ton papa
Désolé j'ai...
été un peu long
(autoradio)
Vous allez nous rappeler les règles
A appliquer
A suivre
si on veut être drôle et ne pas choquer ?
On va essayer
En chanson
Laura Laune...
On vous encourage !
L'humour c'est très très compliqué
Y'a des règles à respecter
Faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit...